this will be his fourth start he is one
and one he started against the tigers
last week and he didn't fare very well
it was a short start for him just two
and two thirds inning so you know he's
going to come back and look for it gotta
bring up miguel cabrera our ground ball
but right at jose ramirez
and the tigers go one two three for the
tigers is michael fulmer michael's
making his fourth start of the season
did not factor in the decisions last
time out like pletco face the indians in
that game and now here's francisco
lindor
on the ground nice play by candelario
you get the lead runner and they turn
the double play with fulmer covering
the [ __ ] swung on
and another high pop
jose ramirez third baseman behind the
bag at third with the catch and adam
kletko looking awfully sharp tonight the
indians have two men aboard nobody out
in the second no score and this is where
it's been tough for the indians tyler
naquin with a hit in three straight
games and a hard smash into center field
it got by good room
and that's going to score santana frank
neal goes to third and in and safely
barely is naked with an rbi double and
the indians will play from in front they
lead it one to nothing naquin with his
second double and his fourth run
still nobody out for domingo santana
there's a ball hit to short he'll get
the out the indians will get her on give
domingo rbi number nine two-nothing
indians well maybe delano the shields
can pick him up with a two-out hit
bulmer knocks it down will he recover in
time here's the throw the shields beats
at the throw was wide and the indians
get another run it's three to nothing
front meal reyes will bat with two down
a runner on and the indians up three
nothing the pitch a swing and a long
drive to deep right center field by
reyes it is gone
and from
reyes puts the indians up five to
nothing he had three home runs at
comerica park last weekend
and fran mio reyes has hit a two out two
run homer to right center tonight
giving him six on the year 18 rbis and
it's five nothing indians
a board with one down and jonathan scope
oh launches one to deep left that is
powered big time and that ball is way
out of here a two-run blast for jonathan
scope tigers back in it 5-2 try man that
was crushed look at the back hips right
there see how that's his back foot
stayed underneath him that's how you
transfer your weight he stays through
the baseball and that's why he's able to
drive that ball a long way to left field
base is loaded for austin romine
the line drive base hit into right field
that's going to move everybody up 90
feet candelario into score rbi for
austin romine and it's now a 5-3 game
was still only one out and the bases
remain loaded oh smoke to left way back
grand slam
for the rookie eastside
attaboy he'll never forget that one
that's his first major league home run
esau paradis smoked it to left
his first career major league homer
and he does it in style he's got eight
nine and one with the lineup austin
romine the three two gays swung and
missed at a breaking ball out of the
zone
got him so dominic leon with a couple of
strikeouts to start here in the sixth
inning top of the order nico goodram
tell you what dominic leon with a really
impressive outing here in the sixth
inning jose cisnero facing tyler naquin
down he goes climb the ladder right
there good sequence
[Applause]
the 3-2
oh how did he lay off it was in there
for a strike anyway
santana doesn't like it but cisnero has
now struck out three of the first four
batters he's faced
here come the tigers in the seventh to
two three and four hitters
turns on one to deep right and that
ball's out of here
should be his second homer of the year
it is and the third homer of the night
for the tigers
one run scored two guys on runners at
second and third for jamer who's been
pretty hot himself first pitch
looper to left and it will one run is
home it's cabrera scope being waved home
as well
the throw will not make it and jonathan
scope scores the tigers with two more
here in the seventh it's double-digit
runs for detroit facing tyler naquin now
here's the payoff to naquen
sent to left
and reyes with a diving grab
he took the gamble he got a good jump he
knew that ball was going to fade in
front of him but i like it you got five
runs to work with go ahead take a chance
reyes does have that two-run homer back
in the third the o2
it's finally over the tigers beat the
indians
for the first time in
499 days